[Música]
gracias por estar aquí gracias por
escucharme hoy
siento que ha estado corriendo una
maratón por años hasta llegar a este día
una maratón cargada de estrés de
emociones extremas y de momentos en los
que he tenido que tomar decisiones con
cero margen de error
verán
hace 10 años fui madre por primera vez
algo que siempre quise hacer
madre de un precioso bebé que al nacer
parecía un muñequito de porcelana
piel blanca mejillas rosadas labios
rojos
su nombre santiago
siempre digo que tuve seis semanas de
gracia después de su nacimiento
aprendí amamantarlo y aunque no crecía
ni engordaba como se suponía que debía
hacerlo yo estaba tranquila porque lo
había llevado a tres pediatras distintos
en buscando respuestas y todos dijeron
que estaba bien
con el paso de los días santiago comenzó
a ponerse amarillo y se veía muy delgado
sus ojos su piel y su pediatra de
lactancia me pidió ver el color de sus
cacas un pañal sucio
cuando lo vio dijo que eran pálidas que
estaban casi blancas
y me pidió que lo llevara a una urgencia
infantil y que dijera que tenía las
heces alcohólicas
yo no tenía ni idea de que podía
tratarse de algo grave y a pesar de ser
muy curiosa por naturaleza como buena
periodista ni siquiera me preocupe por
buscar las palabras en google
lo llevamos al hospital
nos recibieron
y tras unas analíticas de sangre y una
ecografía abdominal el médico que nos
atendió nos pidió que esperáramos en un
box porque vendría a hablar con nosotros
el cirujano del equipo
entonces comencé a preocuparme
imaginaros esta escena
un padre y una madre con su bebé de seis
semanas en brazos que pesaba sólo tres
kilos
el cirujano entro se sentó frente a
nosotros y con una cara muy seria nos
dijo
lo que su hijo tiene
no es compatible con la vida
necesitará un trasplante de hígado antes
de que cumpla dos años
ese ha sido sin duda el peor momento de
toda mi vida
mi hijo nació con una enfermedad rara e
incurable llamada síndrome de ala hill
que consiste en una mutación genética
que afecta a la formación de los órganos
y que en nuestro caso afectó
significativamente su hígado aunque
funcionaba no tenía los conductos
internos para drenar las toxinas hacia
el intestino y se acumulaban en su
cuerpo por eso estaba amarillo por eso
sus cacas eran casi blancas y por eso
necesitaría un trasplante
así comenzó metafóricamente mi carrera
por la vida de mi hijo
llena de miedo
sentía que si se moría
yo había fracasado
tenía el peso más grande del mundo sobre
mí pero también la determinación
absoluta de darlo todo por él
mi carrera es por la esperanza por una
mejor calidad de vida de la que se
espera para él y para mí no solo como su
cuidadora sino como persona un ser
humano que lucha contra la adversidad
mientras vive la experiencia de una
enfermedad rara
sabía que con gusto me dejaría la piel
en esta carrera
lo que nunca imaginé fue que esta
carrera me diera vida a mí
hemos vivido todos estos años a pesar de
aquel diagnóstico lapidario y me atrevo
a decir que con bastantes buenos
resultados
no porque hayamos encontrado la cura
para su enfermedad actualmente se está
trabajando en ella
lo digo porque estamos vivos
y porque hemos podido gestionar todos
los retos que la enfermedad nos ha
presentado y que nos sigue presentando
cada día
y porque en el camino hemos elegido
vivir intensamente
porque cuando no hay cura
cada día es un triunfo
aun los malos y se agradecen
y si yo les dijera que la experiencia de
la enfermedad puede hacerlos fuertes y
poderosos
y si les dijera que una enfermedad rara
como el síndrome de 'la ágil puede ser
la oportunidad de sus vidas para
transformarse y para transformar al
mundo para sembrar un legado sostenible
ese legado sostenible de la enfermedad
radica en su potencial para generar un
cambio de visión y de actitud por eso me
siento poderosamente llamada a compartir
con todos la idea de que la enfermedad
no es una desgracia ni un castigo
tampoco es mala suerte
la enfermedad es una experiencia humana
un desequilibrio de salud
y también una oportunidad para amarnos y
para dar amor
para vivir con una conciencia mayor de
lo que significa la gracia de estar
vivos
no sé cuántas personas en la sala hayan
recibido un diagnóstico de una
enfermedad incurable o quizá tengan un
familiar un ser querido que le haya
recibido
que si es fácil no lo es
pero posible sí
y aunque no hay receta única ni perfecta
para gestionar situaciones como estas
yo quiero dejarles tres recomendaciones
que han sido clave en nuestro recorrido
la primera
lo más importante para comenzar a andar
este camino es unirse a otros en la
misma situación
encuentra tu tribu encuentra tu clan
encuentra la comunidad a la que
perteneces sólo ellos sabrán exactamente
lo que estás pasando
la paz y el reconocimiento que recibas
de ellos será crucial para tu
supervivencia
hay un grupo ahí fuera con la misma
condición que tú búscalo y únete y si no
existe créalo las asociaciones de
pacientes están cada vez más organizadas
y funcionan mejor hay foros y grupos en
las redes sociales usa facebook twitter
linkedin whatsapp lo que te venga mejor
investiga y pregunta todo lo que
necesites saber todo lo que te inquiete
la tecnología está a nuestro servicio la
distancia ya no es una barrera para la
comunicación no importa lo rara que sea
tu condición o si la única otra persona
que la tiene está al otro lado del mundo
aún puedes contactarla
paciente que se aísla paciente cuya
calidad de vida se desmejora
mi propuesta es una carrera por la vida
y no en contra de la enfermedad por eso
es tan importante unirse y agruparse no
sólo para ser más y más visibles y para
promover la investigación y para
promover la el desarrollo de nuevos
medicamentos y nuevas terapias sino para
nutrirnos con la experiencia de otros y
para ser sostenible la vida con la
enfermedad
en mi caso comencé buscando todo tipo de
información acerca del síndrome de alaye
durante un tiempo buscaba cuántos años
tenía la persona más longeva con este
síndrome
quería saber cuánto tiempo viviría mi
hijo
necesitaba entender la información
mítica de mi angustia y mis miedos y
aprendí mucho mucho hasta que un día me
di cuenta que saber todo lo que sabía no
me servía para hacer lo que podía hacer
por él
porque yo no era su médico mi tarea era
otra yo era su madre
entonces descubrí mi ámbito de poder lo
que me lleva a la segunda recomendación
reconoce tu poder y tu valor como
paciente o cuidador está claro que no
podemos cambiar la enfermedad ni podemos
hallar la cura a solas lo que sí podemos
hacer es reconocer la vida más allá de
la enfermedad por el tiempo que dure y
en las circunstancias que sea
nadie sabe cuánto tiempo va a vivir y
para vivir hay que querer y para querer
hay que tener razón es llena tu vida de
ellas
encuentra tu motivación en la vida y
reconoce el poder que emana de ti
para mí lo más importante eran los
momentos de gozo y felicidad con mi hijo
por eso me enfoqué en él y procure
brindarle todas las experiencias de
felicidad que pude le gustaba la música
pues en clase de música lo apunté a los
nueve meses le gustaba la naturaleza y
allá iba yo donde fuera a la montaña al
campo al mar
le gustaba mi sonrisa
y aprendimos a reír juntos y lo hacemos
mucho más aún cuando estamos en el
hospital
y la tercera recomendación que quiero
dejarles
es relativizar la situación de la
enfermedad
esto pasa por disfrutar cada momento
por identificar lo que de verdad importa
por invertir nuestro tiempo y energía en
ello
miren
yo me dado cuenta que la vida es el
instante que está transcurriendo en este
preciso momento
y la vida nos brinda muchas
oportunidades para disfrutar
que a veces por sencillas las obviamos
yo celebro cada noche que veo dormir a
mi hijo en su cama porque está en casa y
no en el hospital
celebro cada mañana que lo veo vestirse
y ponerse su uniforme del colegio y que
yo puedo trabajar
todo es relativo
la enfermedad no nos define
nosotros podemos darle sentido a la
experiencia
y cuando somos capaces de hacer que
pasen las cosas que queremos que pasen
porque nos unimos a esta lucha por la
vida porque participamos activamente en
nuestra salud y en el bienestar de los
demás
entonces sabemos y sentimos que estamos
triunfando
y entonces entendemos que todo el camino
andado con la enfermedad ha valido la
pena
para terminar quiero contarles que
santiago fue trasplantado de hígado con
éxito a los tres años y medio
su padre fue su donante
ahora tiene 10 años y además tiene un
hermano
y es un niño muy feliz
sueña con ser cantante actor pintor e
incluso diseñador de moda
es totalmente consciente de su condición
de salud y la tiene perfectamente
integrada en su vida
esta es una carrera de fondo que se
puede superar
yo los invito
atreverse
a tener una nueva mirada de la
enfermedad
no verla como una desgracia o un castigo
sino verla como una aliada que viene a
mostrarte nuevas posibilidades
explora nuevas posibilidades las que
quieras cada quien escoge su camino
pero podría ser porque no
un camino de amor y de servicio por los
demás muchas gracias
[Aplausos]